good morning gamers it's time for
another
episode of minecraft is anyone surprised
is anyone surprised today we're gonna
have a fun day aren't we jeb
oh you now you don't look at me wake up
chad wake up there you are now
here you go we're gonna have fun today
that's right we're gonna build you a new
home
aren't you excited
[Music]
ignore that for now uh i need to find
sven there where is he
there you are sven today very special
day for sven
sven my favorite dog let's i want to
show you guys i finished the house
it looks pretty epic sven hasn't seen it
either
he has a blindfold on i'm gonna remove
it right what are you doing
what are you doing can i write oh my god
oh i'm killing him how
what happened ah so here we are this is
uh
the house then come on come in come in
let me show you here i have bone
you tell me you can't get up there sven
why does everything have to be so hard
there we go thank you
we're released virgin turtle from his
prison
can you please get up all right he'll
teleport
anyway this is the house it's pretty
epic
um you enter here secret door and then
here you have
bing bong bing bong beautiful backyard
it lits up with lanterns in the
in the summer and then we have all of
the storage
tucked away nice in the floor we have
storage here
so much storage very epic
uh bed is here and you can jump on bed
if you feel like
and uh the best the best part about this
sven please get up
oh he's sitting that's why sorry you
know the best part about this is that
you guys have been telling me
i should build a doghouse for sven and
this is
my reveal sven this is your house
that's right i built this for you sven i
know you love anime and stuff so i built
this
japanese for you you're welcome
okay bye bye have fun sven
it's time for me to build something for
water sheep
that i don't want smith to see
a creeper blew up my farm and all my
chickens disappeared by the way
i know f's in the chat so let's use our
mind here how can we
make watersheep understand that we don't
like him
i know there's like pistons but i never
really use these like redstone stuff
oh my god look he's talking to spider i
knew he was evil
why were you talking about it wait let
me get some cobblestone so how does this
work
and i'll just place it here no wait that
won't work oh god
oh this is disgusting i have to enter
water sheep's cave
ill ill oh i'm this is so nasty here oh
my god how do you live
here this is terrible how do i get out
all right you better not escape you
better not escape
there will be pain this is the worst day
of your life water sheep
okay wait so do i literally just can you
freak off wait the water's not coming in
what a sheep head needs water to
oh survive god you like this water sheep
good because you're not supposed to
anytime
you look at sven this is what happens
think about it was it worth it was it
was that
you did this by the way you did this
what if i
what if i add another piston so he gets
squeezed from many angles
i like that wood redstone and iron
okay let's make three can we give
can we give water sheep like a bad
potion
potion of harming i don't care about
your excuses
it wasn't me it was gloria burger
it doesn't matter gloria borge isn't
real
everyone knows that enough with the lies
[Music]
to stop lying if you stop lying then
maybe
i would reconsider being a little less
aggressive
don't you dare escape there is no escape
don't even think for a second that you
are safe
because you are not just because i'm
next to you
doesn't mean i want to hold you and tell
you it's all right it means i don't like
you
water sheep more like piece of sheep
dude this is gonna hurt i'm not gonna
lie
this is gonna be ex this will be
extremely painful
for water sheep
all right so i need to connect these
right see i'm uh i'm a minecraft veteran
so i know
i know the ins and outs so these all did
i break it what happened
oh it pushes away its own redstone when
i use it
look
[Music]
oh no it broke it can't be too fast
no one's ever done this don't try and
escape now water sheep
look at him i don't care
you mean nothing to me i wish you were
just quiet
and took it like at least like a sheep
oh sorry
oh sorry sorry i actually did
can i not put redstone on ceilings what
is this
oh
all right i like that i like that ah no
water sheep you did this
you did this you did this oh my god
how dare you oh i'm gonna up we're gonna
go harder now
we're gonna go i'm i was holding back
before because i
pitted you but now can we add like
spikes
on that on the piston what would i put
on a piston to really hurt someone
you can make sticky pistons right let me
do that instead i know this
this sucks but i gotta i gotta get back
my slime ball
from my trampoline hopefully i can make
it into slime ball yeah i can alright
and then you better not go anywhere
stupid sheath oh i know
[Laughter]
your friends aren't here to save you if
we place
this here he's escaping go back in
go back in go back in there there will
be serious consequences
there you go all right so now can we put
this on top here
nope damn it are you kidding me
come on come on dude
let me do it maybe it's one of those
where it goes in
that direction you're facing no all
right well
i guess we can keep we can keep that
here just to make him scared
oh i know exactly what block we can put
on sticky piss
this one because she should actually
damage him right
oh my am i laughing
okay okay oh oh okay okay okay hey what
a sheep
time for pain oh it actually works
[Music]
it was just supposed to ah
ah i can't believe it
what the sheep was like a father to me
all right we need a new water sheep
i need a new water sheep new volunteer
hey are you coming with me
oh my god
hey hey hey what are you trying to
escape to your war sheep now
you should be proud say goodbye to your
family
that's right you'll never see them again
oh look
look how well accustomed you are to
water huh don't worry you'll still
plenty more water where we're going
come here come here that's right say
goodbye to your friends
oh we actually did
this is your new
this is your new home now that's right
water sheep number two if i can even
call you
get in fine i'll remove it i'll remove
it i'll remove it
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's okay
it's okay it's it's okay
it's okay we're just gonna no nothing
bad is gonna happen
nothing bad is gonna happen and that's a
pewdiepie promise
nothing bad is gonna happen don't worry
oh look who made it in
yes yes yes yes nothing bad
is gonna happen to you my little sheep
just get in there that's right yes
yes nothing bad don't worry don't worry
[Music]
what the sheep used to love this bell
[Music]
oh god i miss him so much
welcome to hell this is your new life
[Music]
this is how you live life now
all right we gotta invent something new
you just stayed
right there watersheep you know it's an
honor and a privilege to be a watershed
right
you should be thankful you should be
thankful
watershed this is what your forefathers
wanted for you you know follow me
i said follow me i know you're scared
i know that you're scared but it will
all be over
very soon ah i this is what the sheep's
fault
oh god you piss me freaky
be quiet no one literally ass
i've jumped
[Laughter]
now
this is awful i'm sorry i'll put you
down i'll put you down
no
wonder she was like a father to me i
can't believe
oh god
not water sheep not water
i was trying to make him bounce in the
water i wasn't actually trying to get
rid of it
what was making him do damage
[Music]
if any i need more water we need to
improve the model
one day we live in a society where
all watersheeps can live together and be
happy
unfortunately this is not our society
all right who's the next tribute if it
isn't chicken sheep huh
come with me come with me chicken sheep
you will pay for what your ancestors
for the crimes of your ancestors i don't
like you by the way
i don't like you oh look at me like that
that's right come with me
thank you for your cooperation just keep
moving
and don't ask any questions you got that
you got that there will be bone
okay now
oh we caught him wait stop that
stop that this that's illegal
illegal move there you go now if we put
a piston
[Music]
uh here maybe
okay let's see all right chicken
it goes through it okay maybe i need to
put the
the famous the famous block of justice
no
that is not what i wanted to do got
diamond pickaxe too strong man
maybe i should have finished the
machinery before i put in the subject
he's escaping oh no
no chicken
chicken sheep was like a father to me
i loved him
oh no
[Music]
water cow why are you not in water why
are you not in water
that's what i thought
say goodbye to your friends
okay actually i gotta take a nap i'll be
right back
oh this is perfect see i realize why i
haven't gotten the
the finer experience of the water sheep
it's because they're not looking like
water sheep there you go
this is how what the ship used to look
like i mean this is water sheet all
right come with me so maybe the problem
is i i put it one too high i
need a i'm so sorry mr sheep oh my god
you're annoying me
now you're annoying me i'm pulling you
out
i'm trying to save your life here
where's my thanks
i mean i don't ask for a medal or
anything don't jump
ah idiot there you go have fun
have fun jump okay this is the
this is what i wanted to happen i wasn't
actually trying i just wanted him to be
forever bouncing
wait he ruined my machinery why my
machinery not function he took out the
electricity oh it worked
so this is what i like this is what i
want no one likes you water sheep
literally no one we did a survey
and it came out that no one liked you
how did that make you feel
no
[Music]
why it not work it's perfect watersheep
has to be in water
but what block can i put to make him
suffer
but not go bye-bye you know what i mean
maybe i've been doing this wrong right
i'm trying to get
to the bottom of water sheep by
targeting water sheep
but in reality watersheep has many many
friends
there's many many cousins and things
like that
maybe this is crazy i know this is crazy
okay come with me don't worry we're not
gonna hurt you we're just gonna talk
we're just gonna talk we're just gonna
talk don't worry don't worry i'll take
care of him i'll take care of him
hey what is she i brought your friend
huh you recognize him your cousin
oh you don't recognize him well how
about now
that's right watersheep i know who your
loved ones are
and i'm not afraid i'm not afraid
i'm not afraid to push them to the limit
to get what i want
that's right oh is it getting hot in
here is it me
water sheep now tell me who do you work
for
huh who said you oh wow it's really
really getting hot and spicy in here
[Music]
what do you work for oh it's getting
really hot just
one more spot left for your little
friend huh
last chance water sheep last chance
who do you work for fine
you are one tough cookie to crack water
sheep i give you that
i'll get through to you one day water
sheep all right so i'm building a
i'm building a giant a giant meatball
for those who wants to know that's what
i'm doing
uh i want to craft uh god it hurts it
hurts to spend these beautiful diamonds
[Music]
but i want to craft a diamond sword that
i want to
damn that's sexy gosh it would suck to
die
when you have all this good stuff for
you i want to enchant it
knock back one sharpness that's surely
better right
and then we're gonna bring some we're
gonna bring our doors
because we're gonna go back to the water
temple uh apparently there's loot that i
didn't get there
and there's like a boss even i like
bosses
and now we also have potion of
underwater breathing
i'll bring two of those and then we have
potion of night vision
i'll bring two of those as well and then
we need the milk to remove
uh the debuff hey hey both cow let me
let me get some of that sweet
num nom nom dude it tastes so good thank
you water cow
oh water cow you taste so good
i can drink you all day water cow you
however
will stay there i think it makes sense
to bring out the
dinner bone
because he can actually ride underwater
how cool is that
stop tackling me stop talking about hey
maybe i should have the aqua infinity
helmet as well
maybe even my trident that might be epic
oh god if i die
i'm gonna be so pissed are you ready
[Laughter]
my head is stuck in the ground get me
out please
okay sorry i think i actually just
remember where it is i don't need the
actual map
okay so once the giant meatball monument
is
uh rebuilt that's when we know that
there will be peas on earth
once the giant meatball is completed
there will be galorean sunshine to
everyone
isn't right right undead jurgen
i like that name under jurgen the normal
you oh sorry about that one
uh on that jurgen how does this look
like on like
another oh my god this is amazing
swedish viking heading out
on his fellow on
swedish god so let's see here
i don't think it actually shows you how
long the potion lasts
so i'm just gonna have to put a timer
hey google
put an eight minute timer so now we
should drink our potions potion of night
vision
and potion of underwater breathing slurp
did i drink it
and then water there you go
okay now whoa it's so bright now
okay we got eight minutes let's let's
ride
so the temple should be here somewhere
don't mind me it's the swedish man
riding his horse
underwater that's right
all right uh i really should have
brought the map shouldn't i
whoa it's so cool i never like
done proper underwater stuff where is
this water temple
we meet that last all right so i'm going
to put
i'm going to put the water
no he fly away so i think if i wear this
it actually makes it so i can still yeah
that's it
i can still dig quite quickly all right
there you go i don't want to lose dinner
bone
let's swim gamers oh there they found me
keep swimming keep swimming i'll go
underneath it much better there's a boat
in front
of it what oh god all right we'll have
to explore another time
yes okay so here we are we haven't got
the debuff yet so
when you enter the the place it will
give you like a debuff that says you
cannot pee pee poo poo all right you
can't dig
but since i can i might as well grab
these right these are quite balanced
they're gone there's the debuff it
disappears
once you oh my god oh there's the
guardian we found it oh god oh god okay
that's the guardian now let's take out
these first
i don't like you oh there's guardian oh
he's shooting me you shoot me
let's avoid eye contact felix
just like real life avoid eye contact
like a proper swedish person
these are really annoying to take out
i'm not gonna lie should i just go for
the guardian then
where did the guardian go oh my god i
take damage by hitting the guardian
oh think of sven
you got to do this for sven man and
you're good oh i'm eating what's
happening
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa no
away ah
oh
bye
oh god the arrows shoot so short i can
take this guy out now
nope never mind how much health does
this guy have
i'm hitting him but nothing's happening
oh god it's been eight minutes already
oh
all right all right we'll drink milk
and then i have to quickly drink water
of
water
hey google put alarm eight minutes
yes i got him
he dropped a sponge uh all right this
back i'm stuck
like what's happening
okay i got him i got him okay so you can
use sponges to like remove water and
stuff
so apparently i'm supposed to go to like
the top of the building there you go
secret no here's the sponges perfect
we just got to drink the oh god we got
to drink the milk to won't mind that
i can't find the way out i'm lost
and i'm pretty sure it's close to eight
minutes not good
okay for fish made it in here we must be
close to the exit
there's some sponges i can't believe i
missed them last time
where's the freaking exit i can't find
the exit
panic mode oh
yes i found the exit
all right guys let's calm down
okay i gotta we gotta really quickly
and i'm talking fast look at him
look at him i'm sorry i have the debuff
oh he needs to jump out oh god we gotta
swim fast
oh god i gotta make more potions i
thought two would be well enough
my god i have okay i have two already
okay
oh this sucks okay i have three of them
is this your friend underwater sheep oh
no it's so cute i'm sorry
i'm so ah
why is it not dying
why oh no
i'm sorry god uh
i had to do it i had to make underwater
potion breathing
okay he's still there great
excellent i'll be right back undead
jurgens i'm sorry
we got unsettled business okay let me
see if i can just mine my way through
the top
die you foul scum
gamer jews j fuel
all right yes got em
there's one more hidden oh they all
respawn
i keep getting stuck i need to mark
like find a way to mark i don't know
where not to go
there find the last one yes okay this is
gonna be tough
yeah for your again
i'm actually really nervous i really
need to do this
oh oh i got one
oh god oh god
oh god i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead
no no now
tell me i saved one at least
i did save one i'm going in
the dolphins is by my side let's
freaking go
this gamer is out for blood oh my god oh
my god no
gamer says no he's not here i remember
this
all right i'm gonna review the footage
because i'm a cheater
okay i know where it is
[Music]
what's up here what's up here gamers
no yes it is it is cities i can't move
you're not going anywhere mr puff puff
okay we have potion of water breathing
i ain't freaking around yes i literally
need to hit him one more time are you
kidding me
oh no not again i'm stuck i'm
stuck that's stuck
why does he stop i wasn't even recording
i'm shaking i'm so pissed i kept getting
stuck
i'm so mad i'm so mad stop swimming
oh great just die cool
cool this is awesome i am
i brought all my nether awards with me
apparently i brought all my nether ones
with me
doors i need doors nothing but doors
21 savage no 21 doors
let's freaking go and i need your smurry
let's
freaking go one more hit
i'm so mad if the game didn't just make
me stuck
randomly that would be [ __ ] great
god damn so annoying do they make me
stuck or is was it the game
i'm so mad wait here you're again
what the frick is that did it salesman
seriously spawn
on top of this and he's glitched out too
go doors doors
doors doors the power of doors
okay i found it it's up here oh god
don't get stuck
damn they do so much damage are you
kidding me i'm dead
there it is door
just get the stuff and bounce all right
oh mending those are the best pants in
the game look this is how i got stuck
this is how i get stuck suck
suck okay we got our stuff back that's
all that matters
now we can mine these
am i supposed to use a diamond pickaxe
or is it a shot
sorry spongebob but i need your body to
nourish me now we can mine anything from
well whatever see now we can just mine
our way out
because frick this look at this dude
what are you doing here why do you have
to spawn here out of all places
what does he sell garbage your trash
let's go
first bosses in minecraft killed even
though last one wasn't on camera
i did it okay
i might regret this
why do i get stuck
ah i'm furious now i'm furious
why does he do that if i can just swim
it's fine
i don't get it i had to go and get
another thing why did i do that
cool this is the name of the [ __ ]
game at this point why am i stuck
all the time getting my stuff back i
don't care
how many doors i gotta go through
okay i just need my diamond pickaxe oh i
got it oh
see the reason why i came back was
because
obviously
the other ones floated to the roof
oh god not again get the boat get the
boat get the boat get the boat get the
boat
oh no no no the wrong way oh my god look
at him
how am i supposed to get him back did
you have fun
i need you to get in the boat sir oh my
god
that is not the uh all right let's do
this quick
swim up swim up swim up
okay it's not it's not too far oh my god
where did he go keep sliding
what is with all my pets and underwater
are you kidding me there's a freaking
ravine there
yeah again oh god we lost up
we lost upside down on undead here again
we're gonna have to come back for him oh
my god i'm still
so mad and you know what i've had enough
with you you were the cost of all of
this weren't you
more you no more games
no more play the frick did he go
oh he's dying he's dying don't let him
die
he needs water to survive huh get in
you're pathetic you're pathetic and you
disgust me
i'm gonna give you one chance to
surrender
tell me who you're working for
wrong answer
oh my god no no
sorry i'm sorry you had to see that
all right all right gamers it's been a
long day
with a lot of adventures hey sven
how was it you had a great day
oh that's awesome i'm so happy for you
here have some chicken
how was my day well it's good now sven
it's good now good night gamers
what you never played two for simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price